c'est en décembre 2007 que daniel
rousseau a ressenti les premiers
symptômes de la sela j'ai trois enfants
qui ont maintenant neuf ans 12 ans et 14
ans je joue un père qu'il est très
impliqué dans la vie familiale
on fait ce bouchon de famille j'ai
l'impression d'abandonner ma famille en
partant comme ça dans deux trois quatre
cinq ans et je suis pas prêt partir et
surprennent les séparations en bus alors
un médicament qui contenait l'espoir
d'avoir un à un ami plus ça nous s'amuse
à jeter fait d'avoir un peu d'espoir
programme spécial de santé canada permet
à monsieur rousseau de recevoir depuis
novembre des traitements des d'aravane
un médicament fabriqué par la compagnie
mitsubishi tanabe c'est un traitement et
par intraveineuse sap après nos deux
pochettes que ça prend environ une heure
pour pouvoir aller aucun médicament qui
y laissera alors c'est ce que ces procès
de fer sont les skis nick c'est de
ralentir la médecine environ 30 35% en
18 mois la maladie s'est attaqué à ses
jambes et assez mais les monsieur
rousseau arrive toujours à bien respirer
à manger et à boire mon neurologue m'a
dit que je porte à une mesure un bon
bouquin parce que j'ai encore une
capacité pulmonaire 100% et chant choral
de voir un enjeu normalement le fait
d'avoir d'espoir nous aident à durer
plus longtemps
lorsqu on décourage la fin du périple uv
seuls les patients inscrits au programme
spécial ont droit à lédar havane pour la
vaste majorité des personnes atteintes
de là et c'est là le traitement n'est
tout simplement pas disponibles pour les
médecins c'est très frustrant
à ce stade si vous pouvez pas leur
prescrit oui c'est très frustrant donc
comme vous savez il ya eu négociation
entre santé canada et la compagnie qui a
offert à peu près un peu moins que deux
cents 200 places même s'il est approuvé
par santé canada
il dit toujours une toujours pas
disponibles on a le droit de prescrire
mais il ya nulle part où le patient peut
l'obtenir au canada malheureusement ce
qui bloque c'est une négociation en
termes de prix la compagnie cherche à le
vendre à peu près 200 mille dollars par
année
l' agence gouvernementale qui décide du
prix des médicaments au canada n'est pas
du tout prête à payer ce prix là ils
sont ils veulent pas payer plus que dix
mille dollars
l'alliance pancanadienne pharmaceutiques
qui représentent les provinces et le
fédéral négocie actuellement avec le
fabricant dans l'espoir de faire baisser
le prix de lédar à bonn car en se basant
sur les prix exigés en ce moment et
québec calcule qu'il faudrait débourser
60 2 millions de dollars pour traiter
seulement 330 personnes atteintes de la
sl à sa frappe pour les patients à de
savoir que cette option est qu'ils ont
pas accès parce que l'autre espoir ces
deux d'être sur ce médicament de
recevoir le médicament de ralentir la
progression de la maladie et
éventuellement de pouvoir avoir accès à
de nouvelles thérapies également une
brute de recherche qui est très
prometteur mais ça prend des années de
recherche dans mon corps dans le cas des
gens qui ont un seul en ce moment il y
au port grand espoir d'avoir quelque
chose peut améliorer nos conditions
mais ce qu'on peut espérer c'est avoir
plus de temps avec ma famille